Joe Biden's brain and body because he is
in um
what he is facing very serious what is
it senescence is that is that the word
senescence senescence senescence yes uh
he's old yeah to to translate that
breaking Biden Falls during Air Force
commencement ceremony on video yeah this
was brutal when I saw this I'm gonna
let's let's let's make this a video big
so you can uh watch
call this crumpling to the ground
yo that was bad the reaction of
everybody oh and then he can't get up
did they cheer yeah they did that's
sharing somewhere somewhere I think they
screamed like I maybe they thought he
got shot or something but he doesn't
have the muscle Master lift himself up
see screaming yeah
yeah took it bigger there there's
another oh this is there's another other
angles yeah really shows a girl walking
towards it watching him fall and turning
and walking away we just have him
falling up the stairs Jack busovic
tweeted it earlier yeah let me see if I
can find uh pasobic's tweet
this is rough man this is the the
commander of our military and he who's
having a hard time getting himself up
off the ground after he fell why did he
even fall
you can see a black sandbag at the
bottom of the left and he points back at
something when they stand him back up
too so he did it does look like he
tripped over something but still anytime
like it's old trips and falls it's never
it can cause serious issues she's like
you're thinking Trump's reaction here we
go
he's at the Air Force Academy
he actually fell down
well I hope he wasn't hurt I hope he
wasn't hurt but it's the whole thing is
look the whole thing is crazy
you got to be careful about that you got
to be careful about that because you
don't you don't want that even if you
have to tip toe down a ramp
oh my god dude he's so funny man he's
tight did you guys see someone retweeted
the old article from CNN it was like why
what are they what do they call it it's
like why the ramp story matters and it
shows Trump walking it's it's like a
smooth metal ramp with rain on it yeah
yeah what is Trump supposed to do
running slide down one of my favorite
articles everyone that's like this
proves he has Dimension then you watch
something like that and you're like he
doesn't have dementia he's he's throwing
out bangers yeah okay let let's be real
I'm gonna play this video for you guys
one more time I'm gonna uh we'll zoom in
on it all right
[Applause]
oh all right okay here's here's what I
want to highlight all right let's let's
get the slo-mo replay here he's he's
standing here look at his left leg his
left leg does not go up his right leg
goes forward and then he goes straight
down yeah so so his left leg either
tripped over something or he double
stepped or tripped over his own foot
this guy in the front is having the time
of his life let's do it on the right
the biggest moment look at him ready yes
he's like yes I mean he just graduated
so he's getting commissioned and the
president's right there I mean you know
oh my God he is just living the dream
right he's not a good president but
still it's got to be feel good to be
graduating and that's the scene forever
now but so here's here's what I'm saying
you can argue oh there's a sandbag on
there's a there's a sandbag on stage or
whatever and it's like dude no no no no
no is there any video where we see the
ground yeah you can if you scroll
forward yeah okay there just a little
bit right there you see the black thing
on the bottom left corner okay right
there
you can see it right here why was there
a sandbag but why did he turn left and
just fall yeah I think it's an excuse I
think I think he just fell as an old man
oh and then he points like oh something
happened no no no no look look look was
his right foot in the sandbag already
because look at his look at his I'm
sorry his left leg look at his left leg
it doesn't he goes forward she twists
and then he's on it and then he falls it
almost looks like he was propping his
foot like his foot was on the side of
his foot was connected to the sandbag
and when he turned his foot his leg
never actually turned you can see it I
don't want it it's turning I don't want
to be too hard on him for falling on
stage I've fallen on stage in fact at
the Turning Point USA event
because if you don't do your diligence
before the performance and you don't
Scout the stage and get familiar with
where the pits are where the chords are
where the yeah and then lights are
behind you're looking at the audience
you've got Bright Lights yeah
um it can it can be dangerous so you got
to know stage presence but it's his
inability to get back up that really
concerns me oh yeah he tries to lift
himself up and can't and they have to
help him up yeah well that's what
happened when he fell on the stairs too
he was like kept getting blown around by
the by the wind he couldn't get back up
well when he fell up the stairs he got
back up real quick did he I thought yeah
numerous times okay yeah
numerous times
really fast yeah it could be
disorienting to you know if he'd just
fallen and like didn't really know what
happened and all of a sudden was on the
ground and trying to get his you know
and he's also obviously got dementia so
you know just trying to figure out from
there
like just being a person whose brain
isn't even all there like what just
happened trying to make his hands go in
the right place
I was thinking that the world ended on
December December uh 2012. because I'm
just like and I'm kidding by the way but
you know it really does feel like the
Mayans is what it was that prediction
was that the world that we knew ended
and that was and that's a good bit but
I'm thinking about how uh I can't
remember what was going on we were we
were hanging out somewhere and uh I
played I think I was playing Three Dog
Night
and then somebody said to me like oh
you're you're like playing the oldies
and I was like isn't that funny I don't
know what year was three dog now like
late 60s yeah earlier and I'm like if
you were a kid in the 90s and someone
put on three dog night it was old yeah
and it was 25 year old music now I
turned I go to a grocery store I go to a
restaurant and they're playing Stone
Temple Pilots on the Oldies Channel and
it's just like something happened in our
society where everything just stopped
being real the way we knew it and maybe
it's just because we didn't live in
those times
but like I look at this video here's why
I bring it up I look at this video and
I'm like there's there's no way this is
what the American Office of the
presidency was supposed to be right like
something doesn't make sense even Donald
Trump was weird people conspiracy you
have a conspiracy when they turned on
that Adam Smasher
opened a hole in the space-time
Continuum and unleash whatever the hell
has happened people think that the
Hadron Collider turning on triggered the
oncoming of Trump no it was Biden
it was like Trump was supposed to happen
because he's a he's a he's a Maverick
and he's like Reagan in a certain sense
but Biden so when I when I see him fall
here and I'm like does no one around
think something is wrong like dude this
is how many times has he Fallen they're
gonna have him run again it's it I it
feels like
everybody is standing around watching
The Naked Emperor walk down the street
and they're all like oh how wonderful
how amazing and I'm just like dude has
this country already fallen apart I
think they have control they have
whoever is really pulling the strings
because it is not him no no I I think
the opposite there's no control they're
like they're they're it's it's 2019
they're like what do we do what do we do
I don't know Trump's gonna win again
well they have Joe Biden he's like are
you crazy Joe I don't know what to do
he's a puppet of I I would think
honestly I mean if I want to go into my
other conspiracy about this it's a
puppet of who Obama I I just it's all
it's Obama's agenda and this was his
vice president and so he can't run three
terms
Hillary in 2016. yeah yeah so he's uh
he's the one pulling this that's my
that's my theory I could be wrong
possible I mean a lot of people think
that doesn't Obama live right by the
White House yes
but I I look at this and I just can't
believe there's any real organizing
Force I mean certainly there are people
with power but the Democrats have no one
the problem on the right right now is
that there's too many Trump and DeSantis
are too good they're both too good and
now people are like well Santa is bad no
Trump is bad and it's like they're both
just really good and arguing about who's
better and then you've you like look
even Tim Scott is good and you know
Christy gnome is good I don't think
they'll win but there's a big lineup of
high profile people on the right yes
with two major contenders of course
Trump being the obvious front runner and
the Democrats side there's nothing
literal nothing Gavin Newsom but barely
and like Michelle Obama or Oprah yeah
but you know George solaro's son has
taken over his legacy as well and has
full access to the White House that came
out a couple months ago so he he visited
the White House a ton of times last year
so he's basically taken over his dad's
white house visits George soros's son
I'm just saying you know when I bring up
the music stuff
it feels like there was a cultural
cohesion to this country that things may
have been bad at some times there may
have been crime in like the 80s in New
York and all that stuff but there was a
cohesion to it now it feels like
everyone knows it's not real anymore and
it's it's all broken apart right like
how would you we could describe the 70s
we can describe the 80s we can describe
the 90s we can describe the 60s we can
describe the 50s we can describe the
changes and when they were coming into
place we can talk about how in the late
60s the clothing started changing which
became the dominant trends of the 70s
and then the late 70s clothing started
changing and then we saw the dominant
trends of the 80s and you know what like
hot neon tiger striped hot pants or
whatever remind me and in the 90s with
like you know flannels and acoustic
guitars or whatever jenko jeans with
hip-hop and all that yeah and then the
2000s the 2010s and and the 2020s are a
blur of mangled nonsense I think that
was also the internet and so all of
these all of because the the the trends
used to come from
the coast and they'd move inward so like
Boston California you know those would
be the trendy places and they'd that's
where the trends would pick up and
they'd move inward but now we have the
internet where everybody gets everything
at the same time and all the trends are
shifting and everybody wants to be the
next big thing and what we get is a
show we get chaos so it all happens at
once yeah it's completely it's
information overload but I I mean what
you said earlier I think that there
should be an age limit to when you can
run for president run for Congress
everything like that I mean there's who
is it is it the congresswoman Dianne
Feinstein yes who was wheelchaired into
the she looks like the Crypt Keeper and
she asked Kamala Harris what are you
doing up here yeah when she was speaking
when she was presiding over the Senate
she's there to check the box I mean and
she's just I mean she doesn't know what
she's doing there yet she's casting
votes yes at the least a grip strength
test of grip strength because that's
like an indication of muscular atrophy
if you can't pick yourself up off the
ground I don't think you're fit to
command
um yeah let alone the mental stuff
that's a little more challenging of like
are you smart enough to do the job like
who tests for that and I mean you got to
look at honestly like like after 9 11.
George Bush like went to ground zero and
put his arm around the firefighters like
we're gonna do what you know and he was
just this force that everyone you know
felt safe watching after this horrible
event happened would you feel safe being
in the hands of Joe Biden after after
this awful event happened no no I feel
like I got to protect him yes exactly
that's your instinct you know just as a
human being like this is an elderly man
who's being exploited I was thinking a
couple days ago the United States it's
not really a country it's not a place
it's an idea of a bunch of states that
have decided to unite for the betterment
of all the states and we could
technically have that all over Earth
like we could have a Giants States
United across earth whatever the United
States there here we are now it's just
more States in action but this one man
it's it seems like the last 20 years
started to interrupt have been a bit
like you said earlier chaos I think you
mentioned that case I I don't know if
it's true through but there's that line
in National Treasure where I think it's
Nicholas Cage he says that before the
Civil War people would say the United
States are and then afterwards they
would say the United States is in these
United States yeah exactly because there
was an idea that the states were each
what they are 50 separate Sovereign
entities with a trade agreement is is
what the states are but then after that
it became really cohesive and it was
like one thing so where we are the
United States we are one entity and and
you you think about it like we the
states are really Blended together
people didn't really understand the
purpose of them because of civics not
being taught in schools and things like
that people didn't understand this so
now since covid we're getting
we're getting 50 separate states that
you can clearly identify like you're
going to go to Florida because they're
not going to give sex changes to
children not because it's sunny like
you're you're going there now because
the kids are safe you know you're not
you're not gonna go to California
because you want to see the Hollywood
Walk of Fame because you'll probably get
murdered you're going there now because
you want to visit Wine Country up north
where it's safe thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time